a massive Arctic chill is moving over
much of the country right now bringing
bone-chilling cold that's never good and
oh yeah snow - more than 67 million
Americans are under winter weather
alerts this morning forecasters expect
hundreds of cold temperature records to
be broken today this cold and snow will
have people shivering across the central
southern and eastern US through the
middle of the week our lead national
correspondent David Begg know is in
Lockport New York about 40 minutes north
of Buffalo David how cold is it there 31
degrees just cold enough to make this
reporters teeth chatter on national
television look here's the headline this
is the first major snowstorm of the
season for this area you'd expect that
this time of year what you wouldn't
expect is for the snow to stretch as far
south as Tennessee they don't usually
see snow this time of year this is all
part of an arctic blast bringing
sub-freezing temperatures to many parts
of the US let's start in South Dakota
shall we the plains and the Midwest have
seen snow Rapid City South Dakota got
about five inches there was a no travel
advisory that was actually issued
because of how much snow fell in that
city over the weekend to Minneapolis now
vehicles were stuck along a pretty icy
Interstate 35 near downtown temperatures
in Minneapolis this morning started out
in the single digits Minneapolis your
high is expected to be just 17 and to
Iowa snow fell overnight some parts of
Eastern Iowa could get four to six
inches of snow where we are the forecast
calls for about 10 inches of snow but
upstate New York and northern New
England you'll see about six inches
before it's all over all right David
thank you CBS News climate and weather
contributor Jeff bardelli is here Jeff
these low temperatures could break
records in many areas how cold can we
expect it to get some places will feel
below zero get ready to shake and shiver
to put this into perspective by the way
this is about two months early and even
for January temperatures will be below
normal
looking at the map you can see the core
of the cold air tonight and tomorrow
surges east across places like the Ohio
Valley and into the Great Lakes and then
overtakes the whole eastern half of the
nation as we head into Wednesday
literally two-thirds to the eastern half
of
country will be covered in temperatures
that are near freezing or below freezing
that's how cold it's going to be all
right feels like temperatures this
morning near zero in the Upper Midwest
watch what happens later look at Dallas
it's 32 and then temperatures begin to
surge down by tomorrow morning it feels
like 14 in Dallas feels like 10 in
Nashville 4 below in Chicago that's how
cold it's going to be
and tomorrow Philadelphia is 49 and then
bang temperatures surge down to 14 in
Philadelphia feels like temperatures and
seven in Boston
snow is gonna be a big deal Chicago
three to six inches of snow during the
day today but the heaviest snow upstate
New York Vermont New Hampshire could see
up to a foot of snow over the next
couple of days and the first flurries
are possible here in New York City and
in Boston as well
say it ain't so a lot of purple on that
map I'm a little worried get used to it
oh all right it's only fall that's right
thank you very much